my um i'm here guys yeah there's some teams i'm looking at
that are like kind of good like um good morning team that's
him and his brother everyone they're good um fade will be
pretty good right happy feet is going to be the most
annoying team that you encounter i don't know how good joe
is uh joe's a warzone guy i think he's decent at apex but i
don't know if he's like it's i don't think i don't think
joe's bad but zuni zuni and fate are both mouse and key
players and they're known for being like movement players
they're very they're going to i know what fate is yeah yeah
you'll know right away if you're fighting them they'll just
be doing some tweak shit just bouncing around um so how does
a roller player hit like sick guys i'm setting everything up
right now i would hate that man actually if you're used to
not that bad the faster people move in this i'm very much
i'm alive okay so their movement can kind of like you know
it's the little things that i'm alive guys that's part of
what part of why like axel i think axel is so broken on your
life now if you slide past someone it literally just feels
like your aim just glues onto them good morning everyone i
am alive and ready to play the apex legends sound guy i
don't actually don't even know sound guys alive but me no
one's alive at this time i is god is anyone uh there's
everyone's offline everyone's offline normal sound channel
oh wait somebody got on on their phone i need help balancing
it this great house team is actually pretty balanced good
morning everybody welcome to apex legends so so um we found
out that this is the invited uh 40 teams for this tournament
so it's split into two groups and i told mac mean it's cool
if you don't make it to top 10 because i thought it was i
thought even he just found out today because i was the one
that told him i was just like do you know they invited 40
captains and he's like it's round there's there's several
rounds i was like yeah bro it's not one i thought we were
gonna be playing you know what i mean it's not like you know
it's not just it's not one tournament round it's two
tournament rounds a top 10 from each each bracket moves on
to finals and then i was just like today well i'd set it on
max stream because he was streaming all of this i was like
bro it's okay we don't make it past top 10 it's totally fine
it's totally fine
um um yeah so anyway i mean bro okay only top five get money
i thought i'd be i honestly thought we distributed further
but only top five in the final round gets money so i'm
totally cool if we don't how do we just make it a top five
you hate money don't care whoa whoa whoa I'm just saying
there's 40 teens there's a 480 teens that's all I'm saying
yeah 5 out of 40 I am wrong oh I'm so locked.
I'm ready.
Wow.
I had five minutes of warm oven.
That's all I need.
I know for a fact that if this tournament goes on longer
than four hours, I need to take that out for a walk.
During this tournament.
And
take him out for a walk in the middle of this tournament if
that happens are you sure i'm my goal is not last don't tell
mac that oh he heard him he heard he heard his name it's
just like you talking about me i better get my walkies
oh I'm ready maybe I should have warmed up earlier but it is
what it is I mean I could have just sneaked in one little
game that's all right who needs that one little game he's so
excited how many games that's a good question maybe i should
read the rules
let me just let me just read the rules real quick uh Let's
see.
Where the fuck is the rose?
Check-in format.
All right.
Let me look at this.
At least there's no stream delay.
That's what.
Oh, I'm starting to wake up.
I'm starting to wake up now.
My eyes are being less baggy.
I'm makeup starting to get it here.
The energy is starting to get it.
come in me okay four teams each group four games okay it's
four games only all right per group mac did you read the
rules we just need to play four games per group yeah yeah i
thought we were about to play a six game set yeah i was
gonna yeah i was mentally prepping oh yeah i was ready to i
was ready for that too and at least hey four is not too bad
it's not as bad as i thought it'd be yeah see now you want
to make the second set don't you look if we don't make it a
sec i'm cool with that i'm fucked up i said i'm cool with
anything i'm cool with anything can't be cool with a loss
we're here to win lock the in i'm so locked i'm so i'm I'm
so locked back.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to shoot things.
I bet.
You need, like, 200 milligrams of caffeine.
Oh, guys, I should actually get coffee.
Let me order coffee real quick.
It's like, yeah, maybe when I get the coffee, I'll kick in
by the second match.
Like, the first match is the warm-up.
We're fine.
All right, let me order coffee.
coffee all right guys i'm gonna order coffee i'm gonna order
myself a coffee let's go all right see coffee i'll just grab
that oh should have done that way earlier how the funny
thing is that i might have woken up at 8 30 a.m sandwich
dude uh all right where's the coffee caffeine ice coffee all
right caramel macchiato regret give me that caramel
macchiato oh actually i want something sweet yeah i'll take
that we have an egg sandwich too all right
get pastry with that as well whoa they serve brunch oh
that's nice I'm trying so hard right now to be so alive oh
my god that pasta I like pasta I shouldn't eat too much in
the middle of the game that might not be a smart idea okay
just the egg sandwich oh but then it you know i could eat
after i'm getting that pasta like this i have free will all
right directly to me this is my money i'm an adult i'm gonna
use my adult money i'm gonna use my adult money all right
and i'm doing it
earned this adult money for this special occasion after game
pasta let's go
yeah all right guys hello everybody did you guys see the
thing about ingrid with her new game over screen and
everybody's gooning i don't understand i i don't understand
but can someone explain what is erotic about should i
rephrase that what makes it gooner bait
can can someone explain someone was like people were like
this is peak and i'm like I don't understand.
I need someone to explain this.
It's the countdown.
But she's counting.
She's like, Ted, not?
What is it about the countdown?
Oh!
Oh, never mind.
Someone said something and it clicked.
Oh.
i get now i get it i'm one of the boys now you get it now
i'm one of the boys now i know i understand see i see all
these tweets on my timeline about about it it's like it now
i'm awake no i it was something else it might have been
instructions for something game is starting wait game is
game is starting there's one there's one team that has two
players yeah there's one in the other lobby too oh well we
know that team's going to be ratting the whole time what fun
interactive gameplay
Where are we?
Humbert Labs.
Okay, that is not an ideal POI for what we're trying to do.
Okay, we're change of plans.
Change of plans.
What's the new plan?
Doki, Doki, play some caustic.
Where's, okay.
Go Seer, go Seer, go Seer, Shepi.
All right, let's go!
Santa Claus time.
I said I'm going both on my right ones, right?
Mm-hmm.
I was like, okay, God, I'm laughing.
pick I was like where's costing I'm ready unfortunately this
POI we if we hang around the edge it's gonna get weird I
assume so unless the a unless unless it lands on us unless
the ring lands on yeah trust I can kill the warzone guy you
got the pro yeah yeah I'm gonna land on the light or
actually Doki land on the light arsenal where's the light
arsenal where is it on these bins I see it.
Loot these bins, loot the low ground, and then go up.
Land on the north shifty.
All right, let's let you go.
What?
Yeah, we do.
So loot the bins.
You loot the bins, loot inside a couple of the bins, and
then go up.
Oh, what the fuck?
It's not on ALGS mode.
The spring popped way faster than I thought.
Okay.
Just loot the bins in here and then zip up, and then hit the
light arsenal, and then hit the console, Doki.
What?
Okay.
I got you.
all right i'll go hit it now let me know you find a hemlock
how far can i branch out before i run to another team uh
you're good you're good there could be a team up here okay
um all right ring town you could get you could get shot from
old town i'm gonna try to look for you yeah i mean i have
nothing on my seer earlier there you go zone is viaduct i'm
gonna upgrade my r9 bring me a hemlock what do you r9
rampage what about your shields i have only one stack do you
need bats what's about uh one bat actually two bats now come
come come up to me and then we're gonna balloon out to
shifty shifty do you grab that yeah nice what do you want me
to grab for the uh i think it's the left one It's your
increased barrel count.
I'm here.
We're going to start pathing west.
Come on, man.
Ready over here.
Grab this Evo.
Team flying over me.
We're good.
I have unlimited ammo.
You shot a Valkyrie slap me.
I should be fine, though.
By yourself.
Yeah, if you can...
I'm putting a TP down.
Yeah, I'm coming over here.
right now yeah oh okay i'm just gonna be grabbing the tp
yeah just take this and then we're gonna keep having less
from here we're gonna rotate grab this evo and then go along
the south side of the map through shipyard arcade all right
i'm gonna try and see if i can get this evo for us real
quick now they're sitting here they're looking to kill us on
it come this way all right
Just be careful on your cross.
All right.
Yeah, if they're looking for that player, that's got to be
one of the good teams.
God, we're so close.
We're going to slide down.
Did I just see someone in front of us in shipyard?
We might look to kill this team in Chicago if they're still
sitting.
I mean, I don't see anything close to the team.
They were towards the middle of the ship, southwest.
All right.
Why are we hanging out?
They're flying off the balloon.
We can walk up.
They're flying over.
Might be able to kill one.
One might be late.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I still was getting one.
Actually, I'm getting nothing anymore.
All right.
All right, go hit the UAV at the back here, Shifty.
Yeah.
We'll hit that and then see if we can walk in on the
backside of iaduct.
I remember not to grab ammo.
That should have been the old town team.
If iaduct is like fully stuffed...
Oh, we can get in easy.
Easy, easy.
Let's go.
We're gonna wrap south.
And we're gonna bat real quick.
Okay.
I'm right behind you.
You guys good on shields, meds, everything?
You're all good.
Yeah, I'm good on everything.
Yeah, I mean, I'm 8-2 right now, but...
8-2, okay.
That's not bad.
We'll head south.
We're just gonna wrap this backside and come into like the
back buildings here, and then see if we can go into the
little buildings across the bridge to the west.
Bolt PK though, I do want to get rid of this PK.
Okay.
I'm gonna drop a TP in this building.
It was no one of these buildings in front of us.
I'm just letting you scout out first.
Do you have any scans over here?
I'll let me look.
Am I yelping?
I'm just scanning.
But not from where I'm at at least.
No?
Okay.
If we just bump into someone here, we're just gonna fight.
My ADS is the same like radius of my out my fucking...
actually like cute or my l1 right yeah yeah okay that's not
last let's go okay we're just gonna chill back here uh jokie
start setting up barrels just like get barrels on the east
walk up make sure that no one comes from that side or just
i'm gonna go scrap loot the low ground the way that you play
this spot um this is our priority spot here yeah this is
like our defensive corner you're super safe here the little
building is super safe all right um you're gonna want to
look as low left uh i kind of want to get a different gun
and peek at it we want to place some barrels here get some
barrels like by the truck like anywhere around the bridge
trap set all right get some in our spot too we want me to
play them keep an eye out while you set up yeah where
exactly are we going to put them anywhere anywhere you think
is is good if a team like you could put one in this hut so
no one's slam How many traps can I add?
Eight.
Okay, that's a lot.
Just make sure you're scanning around, shifty so you don't
get caught off guard.
Putting a TP down for you.
One, two, three, four, two, four, five, six, seven, five,
six, seven.
I hear shots deep north, but I don't see anything on my
scan.
I can put two more traps.
Your scans, you know like the two stages of your scan,
right?
Like the little blips and then like the full ones?
Yeah, like there's like the little wave in the taiga or
yellow, right?
Yeah.
yeah yellow means they're actually yellow yellow means
they're close and then the blue ones means they're within
like 100 meters okay all right eight traps are up i got one
one shot here they're all taking back where are you guys i'm
gonna look front here let's migrate over there yeah yeah
keep an eye on our east okay that's your primary yeah look
at we don't get wrapped i'm gonna go try to grab more
wingman ammo off of this arsenal yeah i'm like
nemesis peacekeeper now but they don't want this fucking pk
you should probably just keep the vault honestly just be
double energy think so yeah pk is like not great
oh i see someone on this side i saw somebody sliding yeah
I'll double up with you.
They're like here on the house.
I'm going to play up on them a little bit.
I'm not like trying to fight.
I'm just trying to see if I can get a pick.
If I knock one here, then we're going to try to kill this
team.
Cool.
It's right here.
We have nothing on our low left.
One is set out right.
Two here.
Oh.
There's a replay.
I'm going to try and shoot.
them so they don't come to us.
Oh.
There's a team to our left.
With where that team's landing, that's a good sign.
We're in a great spot.
That team has ring three.
They came from shipyard.
Oh, he's pushing up to the bridge just slightly.
Yeah, I'm going to move him slide back a little bit.
He's trying to Vertainade me.
These guys are like close enough for my yellow, by the way.
Yeah, they're gonna stay down there probably.
The zone is gonna be pulling to that corner.
60?
Oh, what?
The team is Axel, Axel Caustic Conduit, by the way.
Alright.
I don't want to peek too much.
I have seven shields.
Little, small shields.
You regen.
We're sitting in zone.
You don't need to heal at all.
Oh, really?
Your shields.
Yeah.
Oh!
The team just fucked their flight up really badly.
The team just flew in over here.
Okay.
They might try to, they're either gonna run into us or run
into the other team.
They're under my bridge.
At least one is under my bridge right now.
I think.
Shift E.D.
Of Scams over.
Yeah.
Let me see.
I have to choose my region.
Yeah, they're not under bridge.
They're like on the other side of the bridge.
Like, yeah, there should be another team here on the right.
I'm playing up a little bit.
I'm not getting anything on the right.
I'm walking up a little bit.
I'm waiting for the region.
Seems like more left.
I just want to give up our full left, though.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
You can stay over there.
What I ever burned my out here just to see.
like riders or no no your old um your old's not really going
to give you scans right now i just got a 30 left yeah pretty
low ammo though i don't really want to waste yeah you're
good basically your old is like if we're fighting your old
is our fight button well you pop it and it just lets you
keep queuing constantly okay and it also gives you a double
jump all right these left guys are kind of taking angles
they're like on this roof just they are able to see you if
you're on like the street level yeah we should be good
they're probably just gonna sit in that building i don't
think they'll flex out towards us at all all right yeah i'm
just like taking petty shots at them i didn't realize you
have regen now oh it's not regenning your rank that's for
sure it happens when you're you're when you're in uh the
circle that's a controller character oh okay all right you
also get an extra bar of shield so you have not playing
controller i
just keep queuing my left hand does anyone wants the four by
eight i have it here i'm good i'm playing a wingman
i want to kill each other guys come on oh there's a somebody
walking in trying to pick something you guys are getting
like knated and pressure really hard over classic one i
almost got him one just died here i'm gonna play up on this
all right do you want me come with you just chill no left
team just chatted left team just padded me left team did it
up here now uh yeah they were on my level back you might
need me they might be trying to play me he jumped down but
he like he did something to get up there i don't know if he
had like back over to you they're just on top i mean you
might be able to come over here and beam one bro this guy's
like sitting on top of the fucking room i'm dropping two
bats if you need uh he's just sitting behind one of those uh
yeah i'm keeping that new character's like ball he's just
literally sitting on the ball on the ball oh yeah yeah let's
beat that again wait oh wait that's okay uh if he has purple
armor he can double jump yeah he's off we have god spot yeah
shifty that team just make sure that they don't come up to
zip ducky can you put one barrel on my yellow well they did
something and he actually got up here like i saw him on this
leg someone has to rotate they're in there they'll more than
likely stay there all right fine put put a barrel on this
thing here too ducky all right there's like a there's like a
ledge with a staircase there put it on the like on the
stairs one layer down you know my guy that's huge there yeah
this east team They kind of backed up.
I don't think they're in the building anymore.
They're rotating.
Two Valkyles north.
They could fly on us here.
Left team just went over here.
Two Valkyles north.
One is flying straight at us.
Oh, one is...
Look at this green trail.
On me, on me, on me, on me, on me.
Yeah, yeah.
Fight them, fight them, fight them, fight them, fight them.
I'm starting to...
Yeah.
I'm swinging the left here.
I'm with you.
Valk did.
Yeah.
I'm going to kill the give me.
Flash, flash, flash.
Kill the castle.
kill the castle i need a bat don't peek the left side of the
bubble you're judging yeah try to prior your life prior your
life we need to back up the reset back up our reset back to
our spot back i got a shot triple take all the way there
yeah they got pushed in our right on our right i'm our right
come down come down i'm giving you a cue i'm giving you a
cue come down do okay i'm kidnapping you down thank you
somebody bled out i'm just gonna bet push you out i think
our I got swung.
Yeah.
I got triple take behind us.
Talk in the corner on me if you need to.
I couldn't.
They mated me out.
He dropped.
He's trying to swing me.
Out to me?
Yeah.
I'm dead.
On the pillar.
Oh.
He's got a kill out of that though.
That was unlucky.
Yeah.
You know, that team just fed face on us.
Yeah, it just got triple take on the side.
I think if I didn't get triple take, I could have dropped
down.
Oh, there's the duo.
Calcet has ruined it all to be honest.
We get points for that.
I don't seen it.
I don't know.
We get two.
Two?
All right.
With the kill points or?
Yeah, that's one.
We got one of those.
I see.
That's crazy that they all entered us there.
They all entered us just to just to die.
Oh, I should have told you to Cyril.
No, I immediately threw it once they land, like before they
land.
I just got a... I got Vout queued on the way down, so I
should like maybe slow down.
I mean, yeah, we shit on the first team, but it's that
second team that just...
I just ran up, yeah.
And I'm pretty sure like the deep team was taking angles.
I don't know if the left team reswung back towards us.
I think that might have been the triple take.
I just know I got...
Once our team landed on us, the team on the other side of
our bridge just sprinted across at us.
Yeah.
that's just unlucky because i had i if i didn't get triple
takes i could have lived there
oh well at least we know that team has a lower placement
than ours that's all that bad team that it did us got zero
also really better weapons too like i was double energy and
i just didn't have much ammo to burn oh we got like a pretty
unlucky po i to be honest we got like what's pretty much
just a rotate POI where you have to like jam into zone yeah
we you know I feel like I didn't do that bad I literally
just got thirded guys like I literally I beamed the givvy
and then I got thirded like where the fuck do I play after
that like yeah I threw my caustic out that you're getting
caustic to and then I got I mean is there anything we could
have done about like getting 30 like that just not get 30
that's just kind of like we we not not to give you I mean we
probably could have tried the turtle just in our spot but I
feel like we just get pinched and die over time yeah
sometimes
you just get like landed on and you die Yeah, because it was
two devout teams.
If it was in one, I mean, they got wiped anyway.
Straight off.
I guess the only other thing is that, like, I threw a cost
of health and then just hope the other team shoots them,
too, while we turtle.
Yeah, he could have tucked in our corner and just, like,
tried to play survival, but I'm pretty sure he just get
pinched.
Yeah, it was just, we get 30 no matter what we do,
situation.
because everyone wants our spot that was a fast ass game wow
coffee is still being made might be an altar band yeah
you're gonna have that by game four yeah i was gonna say i
was like it's just nice i like that like the games are fast
guys we didn't guys the best part about all of that was that
we were not last place that's It's the little things in
life.
We were not last place.
It's all that matters.
Look at that.
The state chalupa that flew on us.
Yeah, I was going to say, the team that landed on us, they
died first.
It was zero points.
I don't know.
I don't know anyone there.
Oh, it's a new lobby.
Oh, it's new lobby every time.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
I can send you code if you need it.
Yeah.
Yes, please.
Uh, yeah.
All right.
Altered ban.
I got banned.
Altered.
Right off the, right off the bat.
I guess it's time for action.
Maybe time for action.
oh my god oh we got 11 our placement was 11 place we got 11
places two points for one kilo i feel like i was kind of
used this when i was fighting all he really does in in
fights is just like obviously the wall hacks and uh
silencing characters if you want a character yeah that's
what i say if i hit him with that if i hit him when the
castle did it would i have stopped him the res no you would
if you were spamming your cue you could have stopped them
from getting their bubble down though the gibby bub yeah so
if i do that again just try to cue the fucking like i guess
the main character i'd just be throwing it just whoever you
hit you hit you know if you if you do hit them and you see
like oh that's a gibby then just like keep throwing it out
of him you know yeah it was which one which one's jens i was
hoping he gets chinese unless he's on a alt account
yesterday team names are not there's no gent in there i mean
if you got closer hey uh wait what no we don't have to ready
up in this no no no if you want a character you just like
blow someone up really easily you could play maggie man
that's my homie so i've been playing maggie pasco days i
feel like she's so bad but like i know i just don't know how
to use her in the game right now she's just finicky i don't
i don't get the ball thing like i get like i get like i like
the her cue like the cue is nice but i mean it's just
whatever you're gonna full commit on someone you just throw
a ball and it just like it gives you damage reduction it
stuns them it just does like it does you think that would
have been more helpful right there like if i would have
balled them they would have just oh yeah they would have
vaporized they would have vaporized they would have died
instantaneously if we had maggie there and it's also good
for givey bow now it doesn't like destroy it it destroys
yeah maggie maggie's the primary counter to that specific
comp yeah that comp doesn't even doesn't work at all like no
one plays it in competitive until maggie's banned hey i have
been using maggie a little bit but then again i've been
playing like more so like uh because i thought i couldn't
pass gold like once i hit gold like i was playing uh just
that rebirth mode that apex has now oh wild card yeah yeah
and i'm just getting like octane aped yeah if i get run some
maggie we'll we'll play we'll play to fight some people
low-key like regardless of where we spawn at i might we
might just like run at people like if we spawn like humbert
again we might just turn around and go kill old town damn
i'm telling you i got that i got the war zone guys bro i got
them trust but what if they aren't the war zone guys then we
bump in the team that's not them I got the gold player for
sure all you have to do is just get your one right just get
your one like a fake gold like I put down a scam planer oh
yeah there's still oh I still eat you this great a lot of
the warzone guys a lot of them would like a long I mean it's
a years ago we'd always play like apex in our offseason
hit masters and the last one i played like i was telling uh
i played with um uh the falcon coach and sikes seeks yeah i
told him i hit masters like i swear to god i did i guess i
didn't i could have swore i was because all the people i
played with they'd always like they were they're all masters
maybe like they hit masters and you're like i'm good i i
definitely had to be diamond or something i know i was close
i thought i was 15k rp but i must have not been like I
thought I just lied to him, but it's just that you're just
like, I did it guys.
But then it's just all your buddies getting it.
Cause for a little bit, I was definitely playing this game
for like a month, like on and off.
I mean, they checked, I think I was, uh, I guess you're
chilling.
Oh, this was years ago where I probably hit like, I guess
close to masters or I don't know diamond, however it goes,
but I didn't hit masters.
I was definitely one right before.
i guess some of the teams like the the gold player got like
they couldn't find either they couldn't find a gold player
in time or the gold player got dropped so they're like i
guess we're running the last couple of seasons we need a
noob but they're like not like you bro yeah yeah yeah
they're like i'd rather just run as a duo you know i'd
rather just well are these tournaments like do people try to
rig them because like that's how our wars on stuff is like
people get like we have you know ams and pros and like
people people try to you know get sleeves yeah it's always
yeah have to looking forward like looking for pros in other
games like so many of them you're a pro on another game but
you didn't peak masses how our twitch rivals goes like the
18 year olds in our scene like they they haven't really
called like like our um the qualifications for being pro on
those is like if you've played the lands like all the 18
year olds who are like pracked who are now pro like they
they haven't gone to a land yet oh that's right the
loopholes i got i saw sweet was was in like one of was
categorized as a content creator because he hasn't been in a
land in a while i was just like wait yeah is it wasn't he i
saw he was on oh my gosh because i was looking at the the
battle fight and i saw sweet was up with a pro yeah he he
hasn't played in two years yeah so then he's counted as like
a content creator isn't bronzy like a pro too bronzy's a
coach a coach okay i know uh soka is playing with uh zionu
and bronzy i know his name but i didn't lose a coach bronzy
hasn't played since i want to say year two he played with
timmy yeah all the little lupus yeah yeah i mean our words
on pyramids are horrible when they do formats like that
because you're just always playing like two teams are just
three pros yeah some of the old ones uh for apex were like
that i i was guilty i was guilty of doing that i mean you
have to you have to do it yeah you have to like one of them
on the line yeah yeah rig or get rigged like you know you
know who dizzy is yeah is that busy busy yeah busy he's like
an og oh yeah he was like the goat he was like the goat of
apex back in the day i busted his ass out of retirement for
one of those twitch really okay that's funny i got him i got
him how big are you guys twitch rivals uh oh actually
remember they got their third team 17 has their third now
they recruited someone it's pretty rare that like apex
deserts like this now because the one i played was like it
was like weird it was like 20 v 20 v 20.
like the last one i played it was like for the new uh like
the just one character drop or whatever it was like the new
skins i don't even know how you guys oh is it the gundam one
yeah i remember that yeah i skipped that one i didn't play
that one yeah i played that one i think it's because they
want to be like more inclusive so it's like not as try hard
and not as sweaty if it's like 20 versus 20 because like
everybody's a winner like type this one with 40 teams that's
a lot of teams
i'd rather play like comp formats to be honest i feel like i
was lost and i was like bro what like yeah because you have
to remember who's on your team yeah yeah that was just and
he had like 30 20 people in coal i was it was just oh all in
call too that's wild you got a damn mmo raid in the yeah
yeah doing the world of warcraft there
all right we're back in it all right let's see where are we
at where's our drop zone you probably just play maggie no
matter what shifty all right and then i'm i'm the wild card
stadium fantastic do I say or conduit right let's put you on
hope I'm not first choice Watson or caustic up to you yay I
can put my skin on yeah guys hey look I'm a new apex legends
that's right
Oh shit, my coffee's coming.
Coffee and my egg sandwich.
Oh my god, that's me.
Okay.
Oh, we're going to white land.
You guys can just split the inside together.
Doki land close to the console so you can hit it right away.
Shifty land on the north side.
And then I'll loot out here.
Better than.
Shit, I'm fucking landing on top.
What are like the best weapons to use?
hemlock r9 in my opinion yeah if you like the re45 you can
use that on maggie that's a 45 on maggie is really good but
it's a weird ass gun if you're not like familiar i like
that's pretty good no i don't know you guys switch the
hemlock off of anything or like i just keep it how it is no
you keep the hemlock i got my guns right off the bed the
hemlock has a grenade launcher on it so like it breaks
utility and it breaks doors and shit yeah so like if
someone's sitting on the door you'll just yell it off and
kill them i'm doing Ring.
Lotus.
What's that?
I'm gonna go to this, uh, get an R9 off of this.
Yeah.
Oh my god, you're not playing district enough.
I'm like, where's the loot?
Where's the loot?
Um, try to be ready to move.
move in like a minute all right i have a read-a-play
the team could walk up from your west so just be careful
about that did you guys see any heavy make sure you grab
that assault then
hey i'm linking some stuff i need heavy i haven't found any
heavy ammo just concerning
just now but if i had more that'd be great i could drop a
bat i have a bottomless amp for it so i dropped a bat right
behind uh i'm good i'll grab it i should also blue light i'm
good we can get uh we can get you purple armor shifty over
here okay just start piling up and then we will go through
this choke and grab this evo and the care package over here
to you i'll take cell for a whole different road so holy
shit you're so far ahead yeah i'm waiting this team is like
here you only have a hundred bullets for my heavy actually i
have a little bit more these guys are sitting here like they
might play for the care package Fuck, where the fuck is...
It looks like they are.
Why is the guy not doing the intercom?
I'm waiting for my coffee.
Can we walk up to this?
Yeah.
Oh, wait a second.
Oh, they're on the roof.
Back up, back up, back up, back up.
He's giving us back shit.
They come.
Yeah, the fight's just fucked.
We'll just go north from here.
We can grab the salt bin and support bin there.
Yeah.
There's a heavy arsenal too, so we can get it.
Hemlocks.
Uh, salt bin might be on the max height.
I think it's right.
Oh, right.
I'm tweaking.
Yeah, it's on the max height.
Uh, once he opens that, you should be able to grab the
support bin, Doki.
You just take the support perk on Watson.
All right.
tribe was not supported anymore i was like why can't i open
this there's a blue stock here blue mag what should i
upgrade for raggy does it smg is a wrecking ball yeah you
want the strafe speed the gun running yeah yeah and you
never have to put your gun away and you move really fast
while you're fighting people you're really hard to track so
it's only when i'm fighting i'm assuming regular ADS and I'm
slow too.
Like, guys.
No, no, you're good.
It's when you have SMGs out.
You're faster than normal.
Move it, like, unarmed speed.
Nice.
Now my food is going to come up.
We want us to come to you.
So you get this EVO?
Yeah, yeah, come here, come.
We're going to grab this EVO and then we're going to grab
the certain console up top of EDM.
All right.
I'm going to see my hemlock real quick and grab some ammo.
Oh, yeah, I should grab the heavy, whatever.
How much do you have?
I should be good.
It's fine.
I can give you some.
I have 265.
I just...
Thank you.
You're on your side.
All right.
Who needs nays?
Oh my god.
Purple bear stabilizer.
I'm good.
We're gonna go.
We're gonna go up into EDAM and go hit this console.
Okay.
The grenade launcher doesn't take any ammo from me, right?
no nope it's just a cool down it's just a pop pop what it's
like it's just a cool down yeah it's just a cool down he's
gonna zip up over here there could be people here playing
fraying three kind of don't think so though because there's
not a lot of evances up here chance placed we should be good
ducky just come come hit console all right i'm coming over
it'd be fine all right body block if i get shot it's your
fault you won't all right here press press e again on it
it'll spawn a balloon um i think we go into galeria and
upgrade our light guns and then play into this compound late
And we'll try to kill anyone that comes through this edge.
Let's hope nobody's there.
Oh, there's my dog.
I'm not going to get anybody here.
Alright, I'm up here.
Let's
grab a little bit.
We can look to grab this evo here, actually.
Yeah, we're going to scrap the display, that I said.
We're going to go grab this evo, and we're going to look for
the next console in Outlaws 1.
Alright.
If there's a team here, then we'll just...
We'll just go away.
I'm gonna go for the console building first and then I'll go
out later on my ones and grab the Eva.
I don't see anyone in the console building.
I just hang left right here.
Yeah, yeah.
Come at me.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Tearing us hard.
I didn't see anyone.
If there is people here, we're just fighting.
All right, let's go.
No, just set this building up, Doki.
Falco from this side of the wall.
I'm blue.
This team could try to land on us, but I doubt it.
I hit one for 60.
All right.
You guys stay here.
Just hold this and control this space.
All right.
I'm going to go grab this Eva real quick.
We're going to get purple armor off of the next zone post.
Where's our main dangers from here?
Like west and east?
Yeah, west, east and south.
If a team comes through here, then they're going to be like
pretty much right on our building, but we'll just play to
fight them.
I'll play in that choke to make sure that no one does.
on our east and west remember how many fences i could put up
again because i don't 12 all right yeah make sure you get
fences on the bottom floor like by the elevator and the
double doors and stuff like that and then on the balconies
yeah it's gonna be like 50 evo off of your upgrade actually
no if i get that care back we'll be good that's all my
fences i'm pretty sure okay i'm not watching our south
anymore i'm gonna play up towards this care package and try
and see if i can and get it for us, so we're purple for the
power weapon.
They're done.
This zone, if people are playing it how I think they are, is
kind of hell, because so many people can be stacked on top
of each other.
I don't know if I'm hearing you, Doki, but it sounds like
it's so unsolved.
There's a very good chance that there is someone south.
Green, maybe.
Keep tabs on it, trust your gut on that.
Want me to readjust the, you're already far gone it's gonna
sit coming back to bring you some heavy i'm good on heavy
right now but also you want me to readjust the fences let me
know now you should be good which which side you want me to
look at just to be sure uh just keep keep your eyes on the
east for now we're gonna hit the console in the next like 10
seconds and then move all right i'm just making sure that no
one can test us for this There's extra heavy on the floor if
any of you need it or want to carry it.
Someone just hit UAV in Galleria so people will come through
that choke later.
Don't you hit the console?
All right, here I go.
Wait, that's not a console.
Here I go.
Gonna hit it.
They're fighting in Galleria.
We might look at their party though.
Let's look at the other console.
All right, here we go.
Do you want me to get the redeploy?
They want to upgrade with this one.
Big drill.
What about for me?
I forgot what your perks are.
Energize healer, power pylon.
Double ultimate's health or sermons and shield cells heal
double?
Double the pylon's health.
Okay, so I don't play greedy.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go see if there's a team playing in this left
choke.
If there isn't, then we can just walk up here and play
through this side.
Oh, wait.
You're dead.
I just shot that.
Oh, okay.
I think you guys come to me.
I am heading over.
Now I take the zip line.
We can stop them from taking this space.
Coming over.
Are you fine?
I'm doing back.
Yeah, I'm fine.
Yeah, I'm good.
Okay.
We're gonna fight this team.
They're playing Newcastle.
Right here.
You can work space on the left.
They're like kind of spread out right now.
We're just like by the street.
Yeah, I see that.
Yeah.
Hopping about.
I'm gonna, can we queue into the tunnel past them and just
play on the defensive?
Ready?
Stack up on me, Doki.
Get to me.
I'm here, I'm here, me, me, me, me.
I'm gonna queue here.
Three, two, one.
Let's go.
Fence the door behind you.
Oh, I'm shooting for you.
You're good.
Fence the door.
Put a gen down in the staircase over here on the right.
All right.
They put it like right here on the slope.
We're playing this height and then we're just making it.
sure that this team doesn't full send into us we're just
playing in front of them no one should be able to really
come up from low ground and the rps easily there should be
another team that comes through that choke late there you go
i'm dropping two extra bats here if you need i'm good on bed
that was a bam yes i am so ducky if you need those go ahead
um she gonna let's go who needs
but we have an evac i think late we're gonna hypothetically
we get a should i fucking your your fence your fence went
away your fence oh okay don't worry i can fix this i got a
little too greedy with my fences just put it back on quick
yeah i lost i think you're still ratting out there yeah i
want to i want to do an evac play out this side if we can
late but if this team just sits here then it's gonna get
fucking weird I hear him closer to the right I think yeah
yeah I think they've literally just been riding there for
like five minutes I'm not in exaggerating I feel so safe in
here don't see anything though oh we're not gonna be safe
soon I just realized we're not gonna be safe soon can you
drill this yeah Jesus, 15 squads only.
I'm just seeing...
I don't think there is anyone here, though.
Yeah, yeah.
We're going to pop an Evac.
Come to me.
Give me your Evac.
Yeah.
We're going to Evac, like, as Zone starts moving over this
wall.
Come up to me.
Come to me.
Yeah, we're all here.
We're all here.
We're going to go up, and we're going to look to land on the
mid-ground.
There's, like, a bridge between these two buildings.
to land on the close side and fight whoever's in front of
us.
If we land and there's people there, instantly ball forward.
Yeah, yeah.
My red ping is where we're trying to go.
We're trying to go here.
I'm just slamming it.
We're good.
We need to get to the next room over.
Stack up on me.
Ready?
Yeah, I'm here.
I'm here.
Three, two, one, queuing over.
If there's people here we're fighting, we're good.
Just fence us up.
Get a gen in here.
I have gen.
Yeah, 82.
I'm going to peek out a little bit.
Oh, yeah.
God rose.
Kill the guy over here.
Nice.
By the bus.
They're hard fighting on the north side of zone.
Careful across you, by the way.
I'm going to look.
I'm looking that back behind us, just in case.
I got two kills over here.
Yeah, I hit a shot.
I blew armor across, by the way.
Okay.
We'll put that down.
We'll just see you guys.
Just so you guys know.
Save your gen.
Okay.
Do you have Vultixels or no?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Do you have any?
Yeah, give them to her.
Yeah, I got some.
Our next play is really fucking weird, so I need to explain
an ability to you.
The double jump on Axel doesn't, if you fall off a ledge,
you don't get a double jump.
So you have to jump.
It functions like an actual, nice.
It functions like an actual double jump.
So I'm going to queue here.
I'm going to queue where I am.
And you're going to jump over this ledge and then double
jump.
to my yellow ping, okay?
That's where we're going.
We're going to height and then we're going to gen and play
the close side of the height.
So I'm gonna slide, jump over on my slide.
All right, I might fuck this up.
And then use the second jump to get to that height.
I believe in you, Doge.
So we have to do it extremely late, but that's where we're
going, okay?
All right.
That's not right, by the way.
Valque is almost cracked.
They're fighting on the blue trailer.
I see it.
Oh, they, whoa.
Yeah, we're gonna show on the side.
Oh, bug.
Oh, shit.
You can raise me.
yeah i'm gonna raise i'm raising yeah just come back inside
and get healthy and then we're gonna go for that play i have
a penis kit do you need it i'm batting no i'm good we're
gonna do this as late as physically possible we should have
to come back here just so we don't like i don't want you to
actually hit my pad and get launched in the zone all right
you ready all right let's see if i can make this just follow
me three two one let's go
down on me oh it did not work oh it did not work i hit that
guy 100 give me you give me an octo key okay that's not me
that's not me okay now it is me yeah i had to break the octo
all right just show the show chris you're fighting love you
you're good they died they died you're playing you're
ranting you're ranting all right look at your mini map if
the zone stops blinking if the circle isn't blinking you're
in all right there you go you're in just you're in you're in
you're in just chill yeah you don't have to shoot anything
back as you can tuck as far back as you can i'm your mini
map as guys drill
that team in the bus off go down that right side of the bus
you can see them through the glass you can get them killed
you got seven there seven three now damn i came up it's my
jump man i swear that did not work dog it's all good bro so
i did not have another jump i clicked it oh i think the team
above you is gonna hit them don't shoot don't shoot don't
Nice.
Oh my god.
That's ballsy.
Got my coffee now.
If you have another drill, drill them and then you can play
to actually kill them yourself.
I'm gonna... I'm so chill too.
I'm chill as well.
That's a good team in there, so they will play to kill you.
You can GL that.
And get rid of his gas.
Yeah.
One just queued out.
Oh, you're a coach.
Oh my god!
Whoa!
Oh my lord.
Wait, I don't think you meant to do that, but you actually
accidentally made an insane play.
That's, yeah, that was a crazy play.
Oh my god.
You meant to break the drone with your ult?
Oh no, no, no.
I just meant to ult in front of me.
Oh, no, that was crazy when you broke it.
Yeah, that's safe.
Should I have lied?
Honestly, I don't know what the fuck that drone is.
I've seen it in the past couple days.
I don't know what it does.
It's Axel's ult.
If it touches you, it sends you about 30 feet in the air.
Okay.
So you, you balling and breaking that.
Yeah.
It was insane.
But yeah, I meant to ult because I feel like that was the
only thing I could do right there.
It was like ult to that.
Yeah.
No, yeah, that's good.
But did you, you made it to the height?
We would have fucked those dudes.
I honestly, so was I supposed to jump like fairly early?
Cause like I did this.
Like I slid off.
You were on the ledge, were you?
once you have to hit the pad and then jump like while still
sliding and then you would have your second jump yeah yeah
so i did that and it said i could jump again and then i hit
the button to jump but never jumped oh i'm surprised you
accidentally touched the ledge you might have i don't think
god i thought i like just slid right out like i slid while
sliding i jumped off watching my regular jump and then like
i was in the air and then like it said i could jump again
for double jump like hit my button i hit it and i didn't do
it it didn't do it that's crazy yeah i think you might have
unless i just didn't i don't know if like i don't know what
i didn't yeah i saw you do it and i was like where did he go
yeah i heard i heard i didn't make it and i was like no but
he said that i thought he was the guy that was knocked in
front of me so when you're like so i thought you were like
you're like use my you're like you were like telling shifty
to use cover and i was just like i'm not shifty like i'm
still alive like i'm sharing my screen i'm sharing my screen
like once i got this notey like i did the jump and it didn't
do anything so like i literally followed you up but like it
tells me that notey that i have double jump now let's see
yeah where did it go yeah you're actually out finesse yeah
because you're like give me your knock and i was right once
i saw that i was i was jumping man that's unfortunate so i
don't know if like maybe i took too long to double jump and
it went away but i think you just got scammed yeah i think
it's just apex bugs i think you just because even if i click
another button like it doesn't matter right like i should
always have like my yeah yeah you should you should have had
your jump there should yeah i literally it it didn't do
anything i was just like yeah you got robbed yeah i thought
you were the guy that got knocked when you're like i messed
up and i was like is that the dead is the knock guy shifty
in front of me like nah and i didn't know how to get up
there so i just wrapped around the right and i killed like a
gibby that was one shot you took the right you did the right
thing after you yeah that's a good play and we got more
points how many points do we get now um that game put us at
i don't know that's a's I was so ready to just like to get
up there and all yeah you were like I'm ready to join the
team actually good weapons I came to like I've actually
checked
you might eat sandwich guys I think I'm gonna play Valk now
if I have a second set after this if we make top 10 I'm
eating my pasta I need my cards
I'm okay I'm getting the energy right now I'm happy I got to
play my skin I get to be dokey bird is that dokey bird from
apex legends I mean
that's me
no he's just like he's really like eyeing my food right now
he's like is this for me oh I feel like and he's like
looking left and right following my food jokie bird that's
jokie bird all right no more leave
leave i'm done eating leave good news gentlemen we are in
the top 10 right now we just gotta keep it i do yeah okay
but my uh my my weakness though is like microing people a
little bit but like macro is what i'm good at generally yeah
but like you don't play with idiots like you really
shouldn't have yeah i usually don't have to calm people's
abilities for them yeah i'm good at like setting our pace on
that no every time i get upgraded i'm like yo right or left
right i was like shooting the grenade launcher like try to
test it out a little bit
i had to code all the dumbest shit they've ever added to
this game bro i think that thing last patch it had like a i
think a 10 second cooldown on it no 25 second cooldown now
the what grenade launcher on the hemlock oh yeah so i didn't
calm people would just be sitting in zone and you just heard
fucking yeah that was pretty good rotate though that's what
i was like you got to be an idea because i was like that i
would have figured there'd be a little there he just knows
what he looks like he knows what he's doing yeah all right
let's see how this tournament is going for us you have eight
points is that like a it's like a stream no it no Oh yeah,
never mind.
I was going to say Bolo said he was streaming, but I guess
he's also in the tournament, so.
There's no like...
I'm surprised there's no casters for it.
I am as well, honestly.
I feel like there should...
Yeah, NiceWake isn't even on.
He's not even on right now.
We can't even watch him?
Yeah, he's not...
No, he's not even online.
That's not...
That's fucked up.
That's what I was like saying.
Like, I'm surprised he didn't get casters.
He got so many people, but not a caster.
all right production wait greek is greek's watch partying
right now oh greek is yeah greek's watch partying just
without the other dynamic duo oh wings out of state right
now ah he's traveling i just see i think greek's the only
one yeah only greek's watch partying it I went to one of the
uh that like the LA ALGS I think it was a championship it's
like when the first like new team won besides uh what's it
the TSM or was it zero those guys I actually don't remember
who won that one that was a long your guys lands are insane
oh dude they're super hype they're also just like super long
like I went all four days because like my homies like a big
uh like apex fan he like plays the game a lot and dude we
were here for like 12 hours every day 12 hours dude it's
like that oh yeah because we get there before the doors even
open yeah i forgot because there's like a lot of groups yeah
yeah yeah dude some days like like if you have a bad run and
you have to do a loser's run bro yeah it isn't actually a
marathon of hell you have to play like 18 games in one day
if you have to do a double losers bracket oh yeah I told my
boy I was like, I'm never doing.
I did 12 hours per day.
I might do like a Saturday and Sunday.
Because he wanted to watch like all the, I don't know.
The groups.
I don't know if TSM went down to lose or like, I don't know.
So I'm pretty sure we watched losers because a team he
really liked was in losers.
You remember what team it is?
But it's also like really weird because it's like, it's like
a couple hours on and then it's like the little break.
on who was like on like we wouldn't like we'd go get food or
something but those days are long yeah the lands the lands
are a good time the ones in japan are actually just like
insane if you've i bet i've been to japan just a bit yeah
i've been there just a visit but like dude they they love
apex so much it's huge over there and like the energy in the
crowd is oh you get to like a sold out arena too right like
30 plus yeah like during the finals yeah yeah that's insane
it's insane bro i was on uh because i'm on twisted minds
right now i don't know if they're in apex but i was on
falcons before they were at the time that's when uh yeah i
was on the warzone team and uh they were like asking about
oh like do you guys want to go to japan like i was like oh
bro i'm so down but then like i got dropped so what cop what
cop do you see we can play the the same shit i'm just gonna
play about okay
all right just gotta be sure
gotta hit up management like you also got those tickets
where do where do the warzone lands go to like what you say
what where do the lands for your game go to uh we well we
were doing ewc which was just in saudi and then we our other
one was it went london vegas vegas we have one in vegas this
year our most recent vegas one had no crowd like it was
horrible like i heard like people just don't go to vegas
anymore too in general yeah land on my yellow ping and loot
loot loot east towards the console what the fuck is your
yellow you can just loot the big you can loot the big
building if you want uh over here okay yeah your ping like
disappeared i guess i was like where is the ping You loot
that building and then loot towards certain console and then
you grab all that stuff over there.
Wait, okay Shifty you just grab the big building and then
like when you're done just grab whatever Extra outside.
There's a wingman here I'm good.
I'm good Yeah, to be honest war zones aren't really like
they don't really take the game serious like that Yeah,
unfortunately, I really supported I was like I guys comp
seeing it would be kind of sick Like I thought it'd be like
pub G, you know, we're like, nah, bro.
We're like we're like looked at Mickey Mouse bro that's
fucked up it's also just not really that many good teams or
the prizes like warzone decent like our our turn our our
worlds are all million plus yeah because it's like funded by
Saudi right yeah and then like they they throw up a note for
their like world series which is their journey but i want to
say like everything's online play a lot on my journeys yeah
should you get console yeah i'm gonna hit our uav let's
start grouping up towards our balloon here all right i'll do
it up this building okay um we're gonna do something it
takes a little bit of finesse all right i hope i don't fuck
hope we don't it up okay so when we go up this balloon
you're gonna dip down until you see your speed number hit
140 and then you're gonna go straight and you're gonna go
over this mountain okay what yeah okay i believe in you guys
if you fuck it up it's okay wait wait wait no repeat it
repeat it as soon as you start flying yeah look at your
speed meter on the left okay let it hit 140 and then
straighten out straight down okay wait dip down to 140 and
then go full straight okay okay okay all right you go all
the way over I'm already at 120.
I don't know.
I'm already at 120.
I'm already...
Oh, shit.
Yeah, okay.
That's the finesse.
There's a guy here.
I'm going to turn around and land by you.
Are you going to die to the timer?
We'll find out.
You okay, Doki?
I'm so healthy.
Okay.
Careful.
There's people at the house down there.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm coming to you.
Oh, my God.
Do you see?
I might be...
You're safe on me.
I'm so safe.
All right, you did it.
They're a Gibby team.
We can fuck with them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I will say, I will say, Mac, it was a team effort that we
both fucked up together.
Holy.
That's to me.
We're gonna fuck all the way out.
Goodbye.
We might have to res them.
Yeah.
They're pushing up a little.
They have a Valk.
We did.
I'll Gibby.
We warned you.
It's okay.
Come here.
I'm gonna pop our Valkal.
Yeah.
Oh, come here.
here.
Hey, I survived.
They got a Valk and a Gibby and somebody else.
I didn't get to see who it was.
Do we even have a crafter in one year us?
Like maybe North Pad.
Yeah, that's kind of where I was thinking.
I have enough syringes.
By enough, I might have enough.
I keep forgetting that we regen now it just fucks with me.
I'm gonna pop an evac here so you can climb north up.
Not used to the region.
Are you flying north bed?
Uh yeah it looks clear.
All right already you went off when you said yeah.
Go to the crafter.
I'll stick his revs.
All right.
Alright.
Grab things on the roof.
Alright, let me go grab it.
Fuck it.
Fuck this.
Oh my god, there were people here.
Well yeah.
Wait, no, yeah, you're fine.
Yeah, yeah, no I meant like, you know what I mean.
I thought there was just someone like crouching in the
corner there.
No, no, that'd be crazy.
Alright, I'm gonna use my only med kit.
Good, all good.
Nothing to worry about.
Should have knocked it in on those Apex guys.
I was just walking out like that.
Yeah, that's odd.
Do you have enough heals to live, Doki?
Yeah.
I have one stack and one plus one.
OK, you should be fine.
I should be fine.
We're going to I'm going to go grab this Evo over here.
You guys can keep going into zone over towards my back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If anyone, I want to know if Shifty has enough heals.
I mean, I could walk.
I mean, I'm in zone.
Oh, you're in zone.
Oh, you're fine then.
You can kill, you can kill these spiders if you need to, and
they'll be off a bunch of a bunch.
You should start killing them for meds.
Yeah.
So then I can also bring some off of you.
I don't see any of the little pod to them.
Oh, I think, yeah, they already killed.
One of them didn't get finished.
They wouldn't be on the map otherwise one of them is still
there.
No, I didn't realize I didn't even go to the park.
Oh, you went the wrong chart.
Oh, yeah, you went.
I was gonna say, I didn't realize there were more spiders in
this joke.
Hey, so I followed Shifty.
I have syringes if you want to.
We can go back.
I have syringes.
I can go.
Come through this way.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I followed him.
I'm very aware of the fuck I'm at.
It's on Mac.
Everything's falling apart right now.
You're doing so great, guys.
I'm a follower.
I'm not a leader.
So there's a team over here.
We're going to sit in zone for a little bit.
Okay, I will say I only have three syringes left.
Oh, I can give you some.
I have nine.
Okay.
I'm dropping you a Phoenix here.
Yeah, all right.
Our little rendezvous intermission there.
It's sort of fucked up.
this up a little.
It's all right.
We're going to go grab the spider so alive and gas.
Be careful.
There was a team coming out of Cascade.
They're probably going for that evo right in front of you.
So just like stagger yourself a little bit.
Yeah, I'm right behind you, Mac.
Unless you wanted me to follow Shifty.
It's too late.
No, no, no.
You're good.
This time.
Oh, I see them.
Their edge is on.
I don't know if they saw me.
I'm going to say this because you wanted me to go.
This is a little too late.
They might, they could be looking for you.
They could have hit the UAV in Cascade and they might just
be looking.
They're not even grabbing the EVO.
I have one.
They should be.
I have one syringe left.
So I'm going to hit.
Yeah, I'm going to hit those.
Yeah, I'm going to hit those and pray to God.
This is our most maybe scuffed red.
Oh, oh, shield cells.
Let's go.
There's two things to Cascade.
good to move for that evo shifty okay let's i grab it though
or they're gonna turn yeah yeah you're good you're good
you're good you can grab it i hope we live we're good
they're fighting those two teams are beefing all right does
anyone have extra syringes because i really don't want to
use the phoenix kit thank you i do all right oh it's time to
play let's get the zone again
I'm so, I feel so healthy.
We're going to go towards Cito, wrap into Jurassic.
I'm good now.
Come through this side late.
We'll be all right.
Just caretop spiders.
Like the water on your left, where that res beacon is.
Someone could peek over from that.
I'm right behind you.
Okay.
I'm going to, there's two dead bodies right here.
Do you think it's worth fluting it?
You could check it, check it for some extra meds if you
need.
might end up sitting in zone again depending on how shit
goes yeah i really need those so that'd be great yeah i
don't think i'll live this oh my god he's rich there's a man
coming through zone behind me this guy has a lot yeah see
that oh and he has a hemlock let's go all right where are we
going there's a man over here on the side of zone go go into
like the no-name area in the middle over
I'm not looking back, Mac.
If you die, I'm not looking back.
That's okay.
I did some stupid shit.
I'm gonna pop two swings and get the fuck out of here.
Okay, that's what I was gonna say.
I'm not looking back at me doing stupid shit.
Let's hope you live.
If anything, maybe there is a crafter to my right.
people on our deep left go right go right go right yeah i'm
going right i'm going right right now all right um this
they're fighting on the right on this nut we're gonna third
party this fight left team is eight like no okay i have zero
red heels we're just playing the third party this fight yeah
i only have small heels if you need some i desperately need
some but i can't touch the zone i know you're like i'm going
there's a team walking up i'm going right just commit bro
they're fighting this hell and ox get in there boys okay
give me sir i'm syringing guys me in this corner they're in
front of us on the nut fighting they're probably resetting
right now yeah i need to hold i'm gonna res i'm gonna
surrender and i'll res you have time you have time because i
need i need a res i need a syringe on the deep love i just
got it took some space
down like to the the other that's just called One just side
the zone.
Run up.
Come up.
I'm coming over.
He ping, ping them, ping them.
I don't know where they are.
On me.
Raid one.
Kostak low.
I have to sit in this house.
I got Kostak.
There's a rape.
There's a rape somewhere.
I'm gonna die on you.
Oh, fuck.
You might have to rest.
I'm going back.
I think he's on the body already.
I think he's on the body.
Grab loot off the bodies, okay.
Yeah, I'm just gonna I'm alting this like this.
What?
Okay.
I knocked someone down, but I did not get a pull, so they
might.
I think they're ready right here.
Yeah, yeah.
Is there any bodies like close?
I can't go into zone.
So you have to get a smadson.
You have 10 seconds.
You grab a body and come.
Grab a body and come.
Okay.
Got it.
This guy resing in gas back here.
I'm going to rocket him so he can get the kill point for
that.
All right.
Oh, sorry.
That's my.
I'm here.
It's fine.
I'm popping an ult Excel.
Oh, God.
it's fine.
It's fine.
Um, I got kill point.
We're good.
Come on.
Oh, behind us behind us.
Oh my God.
This is fine.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
I'm gonna drop all my sororities the moment I drop down in a
Phoenix hit.
Fellas, I do not have a plan.
We're gonna go into this corner, I think.
But there is.
There's a team right here.
There's a fucking team going there.
We're going into this corner over here.
Land on this compound and then walk into the corner on my,
on my yellow pier, okay?
Just play here and control our space and then walk in.
All right, here's my, here's the meds.
I dropped a bunch of syringes.
There's a syridor in northwest somewhere.
Where there's an audio bug.
Matt, get the syringes!
I'm healing!
Give me your overheal.
Okay, okay, okay.
We have to make sure that no one walks in from Pylon into
that spot.
What's Pylon West?
Yeah, yeah, I do.
Here, I'll give you one.
Give me.
How many do you have?
That was my last one.
Okay, that's good.
That's fine.
Just play small, play small, play small.
We can play on this car or on Doki in the corner as well.
The team in Pylon is going to fight over here.
There's a right there.
Free kill.
Really low.
Look at the fat boy.
I got, got, got.
Carty one on the right.
Pop it on the right.
They're right.
Yeah, they're going through the portal.
Oh, I couldn't thirst them.
I'm so sad.
I'm going to play up on this a little bit.
Maybe someone else will thirst them for me.
At least thirst them.
Hifty, you can come to me.
We have backshots on them.
Close.
We can kill everyone on this side.
All three of us come.
Oh, I'm coming over here right now.
I'll just end the wall over here.
There's knocks on both teams.
There's knocks on both teams, Wolfk.
I'm here, I'm here.
I'm literally right behind you.
There's one on the platform here.
But kill that guy.
That guy has, that guy is my KPE.
Thank you.
On the knock here.
Focus this guy.
We declare this.
He's just healing down on the knockdown.
Push.
He's flush.
I think that's fade.
he's on me back two here two here block one that was not
fade nice nice everyone's dead everyone it was fade there
was okay i knew it all right get ready we are going to
valkal up and over this wall grab as much loot as we can
need help oh yeah 20 seconds i'm right behind you okay so i
have no way to gain i have no way to get us information for
the zone so if you see something open we're ping three
spots.
You know, you're each gonna look at one, okay?
Shifty, come, Shifty, Shifty, come.
Shifty, Shifty, Shifty.
All right, I'm on the way.
I'm on the way.
Doki, you're looking to see if this yellow ping is free.
Shifty, you're looking for the red ping, okay?
All right.
I hope I know which.
Okay, there it is.
Actually, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Let's go.
I'm looking at the red.
All right.
The yellow.
Yeah, you're looking at red.
I'm looking at yellow.
Wait, we're both looking at yellow.
Okay.
No, you got it.
Yellow is.
Oh, red looked okay.
Not red.
Now do Hello, yellow is good.
There's people in the building.
That's it.
Just land in here.
Put a gen down on my ping in this corner.
They're playing crypto.
Stal your gem.
Oh, god, donkey.
Yeah, you like you led me at the corner.
What the fuck do you mean I did that?
You- I did not piece away.
I did not piece, oh my god.
I'm putting gen in.
They're playing crypto.
They'm dropping you an old exchanger.
Alright, alright.
I'll pop this right away.
Let me grab.
Alright, fuck it.
Pop it right away.
Safe on me.
I'm trying to.
I don't think it was safe.
I'm going to res.
I'm resing.
Oh, I can't.
I can't get the res.
One close.
I killed one.
I'm going to need him.
Right, right.
Right.
I'm going to try to get the...
Put Jan down.
I couldn't.
Thirst was trying to get out.
Put Jan.
I'm putting Jan.
Res him.
standpoint panic apex you are dog slam oh my god he was on
the other side of my gen all right it's fine everything is
fine everything is fine okay we're all safe there we go uh
now i'm trying to know the scope all right here you want a
really easy gun take this thing no no no i'm good i got this
god all right i'm good i got this all right I still have an
Alt-Excel.
Do you want my...
Do you want my Alt-I'm gonna pop my Alt-Excel.
Yeah, do it.
I'm gonna pop one as well.
We're gonna look for a Valkyl.
Again, I do not have a fucking plan.
I mean, it's working.
It's working, Mac.
It's working.
All right.
No plan has been working for us.
I'm picking up here.
Okay.
We're gonna pop, come to me.
We're gonna pop a Valkyl.
If all else fails, if nothing looks good and I can't call
something in the air, we're gonna swerve back into this
building into the main portion of it all right i'm just
gonna piece together on you i won't leave so i'll follow
whatever your plan is i'm literally connected to you okay
we're swerving back into the building we're gonna we're
gonna go through the side that we came from through the side
that we came from all right we're eating the watson fence
let's go straight fucking through it find us run this play
in here play in here play in here we're in we're in just
drill the team under us all right we make their life hell
you drill like right here right here straight down This is
fine.
On my ramp.
There you go.
Nade.
Careful.
Oh, he's on top of the thing.
Right here.
What the fuck?
Grenade.
I'm okay.
He's gonna heal.
Just let them fight it.
Keep drilling these guys.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's hitting them.
I feel so...
Oh, I see the...
i see them shooting over i'll say hi if you you could put it
like straight down right here like literally saying oh hey
that guy can we can we three to one swing um there is that
team there is that yeah no no no yeah i do i do i do i do
yeah okay peek peek on me and gil right there break that
fence okay yeah they do uh i think they got the rest yeah i
think they got thirsty someone got thirsty here by the way
okay so how we're gonna three to one swing this show i'm
We're gonna- fuck, this team isn't staring at us.
Yeah, that's what I'm seeing.
Does that team just not really do you?
No.
Fellows, I'm gonna be so honest.
We're about to do some stupid shit.
Hey, top one!
We're not wrapping the zone.
We're just going out and swinging left.
We're going out and swinging left.
Just baggie ball the left, alright?
You ready?
I'm ready.
I'm so fucking ready.
I'm making him look at me.
Hey, John.
Pick this spot.
Just chill for a second.
Take this fight and just chill for a second.
You can tuck in this corner.
We need to shoot the bridge off.
I bet.
We need to shoot across.
Shoot across.
Puts it on one.
I got knocked.
Get those.
I'm doing it.
Play the knock.
Break this fence.
I'm trying to.
You're knock his...
Doc is gone.
Knock it gone.
Play to the bin.
The Gibial.
It was a good game.
For what it was.
For what it was, we take those.
Yeah.
You know what?
no plan has that's done very well for us that could have
been a zero pointer easily off the flight but hey we we
turned that shit into like we turned it into gold we turned
it into gold yeah we got a third actually that was a 13
pointer good check bro you said 140 bro i immediately was
flying at 120.
i started off 130 i was like this does not look so good yeah
the flight the 130 and then you have to dip down until your
speed shows 140 and then you straighten out it's hard if it
makes you feel better some of my teammates have also fucked
that up and they fucked it up on land you know it's crazy
that you believed us that much so players can't even do it
don't worry they're gonna do it right off the bat why was
the team that was on that like that little pillar why were
they not getting shot because they had that was the team
from the building on the height they had all that space they
had the building shouldn't the team under us have been
shooting that team uh i think the team under us was that
team under us was them wasn't it i think they were no no the
team they were like literally in the open on the pillar and
i figured like like that other team would have shot them off
of it but like that team ended up winning the game but like
they were it seemed like they were in the fucking open yeah
well they they have mind control so much space that they
can't they can't valve band dude oh my god you're just
getting fucking down what the fuck am i supposed to play
last game though the last lg for this set um like if that
was like a pro lobby would that would that have would that
team have been able to been there uh there wouldn't have
been there would have been a lot more teams alive on that
zone in the pro yeah a lot of teams the building would have
the building team would have gotten pressured by someone
someone would have like someone would have landed in one of
the cubbies of that building like there's a
that building shaped like a y but it has these little like
circle like where we die segmenting it and where we died was
where that those pillar team ended up just taking that space
and like kind of like hopped a wall or whatever and shot us
or whatever like i would have figured that team would have
been shooting them so that team would have been like
pressured and then then we once we killed them then like
realistically like that team shouldn't have even really been
there i don't know that like i'm just nah because that's how
our warzone like you'll they'll see teams and spots and
you're like how the fuck are they not even buying like like
it doesn't make no sense like you were just blacking out no
yeah it's like it's like that it's like that in apex too
sometimes so that's why that's why in particular where we
were like as soon as we were stuck inside i was running
through at least like 10 different options trying to think
of something and it was all bro i'm gonna be honest i'm i'm
surprised how many times we lived that game like we should
have been dead like 20 minutes ago like like i was like
we're We're still alive.
Look at Mike.
Let's go.
We're so poor.
Now look at us.
Yeah.
Guys, that's crazy.
No plan worked out.
No plan was the best plan.
If the other teams don't know what the fuck we're doing, we
don't know what the fuck we're doing.
I think you probably play the same comp, but with...
Wraith?
Would you be on Wraith?
All right.
I mean, it's been working.
It's been working.
I feel like during that life's blast, why I should just rip
the gen off and just just YOLO it.
Because we we just got Gibby ulted into oblivion.
Yeah.
We were we were fucked.
We could have we could have maybe just sent it on that Gibby
team's head and played for third.
We could have just jumped on them like absolute psychos.
see how it goes i didn't know the thing would have been
otherwise i wouldn't have had us hold the ball and then just
kill them when they when they bub yeah we should have just
let it ride fuck it i mean if we plans working let it ride
yeah just hey even if we die after kill after shooting them
that team would have died because they were like they'll be
low you could have Fuck them over.
Last game for this set.
Because I don't know.
I don't even know if we're guaranteed into the next.
If we're guaranteed right now.
But right now we're currently seventh place.
At least we're not last.
That's all that matters.
We're not last.
Let it ride.
Let's camp.
It's a 50-50.
uh i think i said it too now did you all right all right
let's go
all right oh not last person at least it's not the last
person i might have to actually walk my old before the
second set pulls up i thought i thought it's not like i was
just like whatever
I did not, okay, I don't know yet.
We don't know yet.
We don't know if we're in the second set yet, guys.
But if we are, if we are, I gotta walk my dog.
I'm just checking out the other teams.
Who else is?
I'm glad we're not last.
all right good games good games throughout good games
throughout i'm proud of us doing mr heroes and we're we're
they're doing great what is last two points who is i'm not
gonna call guys i'm not gonna be that person and And the
zero in on the last place team, guys.
I won't be that guy.
Guys, they're already last.
I'll just say they're two points.
We won't kick somebody when they're down under.
I mean, they have nothing to lose now.
Unless they win first place.
In the last game, they have nothing to lose.
We know that's a lot.
Yeah, Evil Doki will return and set to.
I'm just surprised.
How fucking far we made it.
I'm just fucking surprised there.
I'm still like, what the fuck?
How did we get here?
with eight kills too.
Oh, look at me, three kills.
I got three kills that game.
That's right.
That's me.
Yeah.
I helped in getting kills there.
I assisted.
Didn't panic or anything.
So composed.
Wasn't freaking out.
Just letting it ride.
I don't even know who I killed to be fair
oh i yeah i did my part so calm so professional
oh i'm just waking up guys it was fun though yeah yeah i
killed someone that oh yeah garfield's in the game guys i
did not realize i mean to be fair you your name to be
anything.
But there's a Rainbow Six Siege player whose name is
Garfield.
I don't know if he's a professional player or if he's a
con... Or is he... I don't even know.
Garfield Rainbow Six Siege.
Yeah.
There's a Rainbow Six Siege player.
I'm not sure if he's a content creator or he's a pro player,
but his name is literally Garfield.
He's Garfield on Twitch.
Damn, that's the dream.
that's that they got garfield they got garfield on their
team now let's see what place they're he's in what's their
placement and what what team is garfield on garfield guild's
team all right guild's team they are they could be
eliminated unless they get a really good game
He still has one more game.
Bro, it's like the person who was named Doki.
Doki in the Rainbow Six Siege.
He was there first.
I could never be Doki.
Oh, yeah.
Speaking of, I need to like...
I need to make my...
Actually, I'm going to make my...
I'm going to make my waiting room for members, guys.
Look at me.
Being productive.
Look at me, go.
Where's my members?
most likely the members is just gonna be us chilling i don't
even know we're gonna get i hope we get stuff done hope we
get work done all right let me make my members waiting room
um okay i'm gonna be a productive person
let's see what is this called this is let me retweet the
thumbnail art and upload the members thumbnail oh lean at
storming streams all right uh black thank you for the five
give the chips thank you thank you let's help me think of
new stream ideas what do you want to do in future member
streams because you know member streams is for you guys you
know I want to make streams that you guys want to watch so
brainstorming streams thumbnail art man this is a long this
is a long intermission the other games were like I swear to
God if we do not get a break between set one or set two
swear to God and you walk my dog I don't care Max team's
going to go in with two players.
I'm not backing.
I need my dog needs to poop and pee.
I'm sorry.
Max will jump in with two players if there is no break in
between.
Because I don't know why.
This is a long-ass intermission for last game.
Okay, starting in 10 seconds.
All right, there we go.
Oh, technical difficulties.
Technical difficulties.
Nobody's casting.
But how is there?
But nobody, there's no casting in it.
I thought there was no official broadcast.
Where is the technical difficulties coming from?
Where is it?
Okay.
The shadow cast.
days mac seemed same comp yep i'm just playing wraith okay
all right cool should i say i'm maggie it was working out
really well
all right
yeah this is like a real a real comp nice the falcon with
with naggy watson is like questionable but this is a real
this one's a real comp yeah i wrote i mean it really helped
the rotations though it really did yeah this is valek's best
map um shifty land on the right joki land on the left first
left there's left okay
sorry i almost forgot my left and right there
should i do spiders immediately or should i just I'm gonna
do the spiders you just keep moving towards the middle you
both should end up like meeting at the light arsenal pretty
much All right at the end of your route Hit beacon when you
can you don't need to like skip any loot just like do your
route hit beacon and then I just got over Okay
Oh Oh nice.
There's a blue back back here I got
a me back and we need it temlock better than the plotline
yeah hemlock's best primary in the game yeah let's pick it
like primary priority right now is like hemlock and then
like 30 30.
i'm doing the ring
yeah you can grab your assault bin too yeah you can grab
your assault bin too while you're next Sir, grab that first.
Shit, I'm already gone.
It's all good.
You're gonna end up circling back, though, anyways.
Actually...
Yeah, craft the bat.
Not this weapon in hand.
We got everything.
Oh, there's an altar cell.
that all right um we're gonna go travel to moby or fucking
evac evac i believe this upgrade will lights away all right
let's get moving you grab your assault on the way up we're
gonna go grab there's another purple here we're gonna skip
that evo we're gonna go grab this care package and then you
grab this one and try to get up into wall all right i'm
behind you i didn't i didn't i didn't understand half of
what you said but i'm right behind you can you can pop pop
your evac shifting and just start coming towards me just to
catch up
i see a hemlock we're gonna grab this care pack and then
we're just gonna wrap up in the wall if the care pack's not
taken that's the first of many nights to go out i see a
hemlock let me know this place isn't looted care pack's
still here don't just keep moving yeah i'm right behind you
uh low key shift are you good with with like a wingman it's
one of maggie's like best guns you take that brick and take
the gun is it take it instead of the hemlock and then dork
you can take your hemlock yippee there amma i'm good at a
lot of ammo all right then just keep moving with me
we're gonna grab this evo and we're gonna try to get like
there's a spot here think we can get oh here shots
eyes a wig man good for my character uh your character is
really good with guns let you stray fast okay all right stay
here run a tp and try to get us up this hill be ready to
take it immediately but don't take it until i tell you to
okay i'll just wait
oh uh do not take it do not take it okay
You're shooting.
Do you have one extra bat?
Yeah.
Okay.
We're going to turn around.
All right.
I have an ult Excel.
Do you want it now?
No, I'm good.
Okay.
We're going to grab this Evo over here and grab the assault
bin.
We might run into a team on this edge.
Like there's a very good chance.
I'll let you take the shots then in front of me.
Oh, can you team?
Oh, yep.
I'm queuing.
Okay.
I'm gonna get up on the height on this rock.
We're just gonna play here for now.
If this team might try to fight us.
Okay.
I'm gonna be up on height.
One's coming out left.
Is that their teammate?
I think that's split.
The wraith is TPing away from the armor.
Yeah, that's our teammate.
Can we run at the armory?
I can't see it.
You and me?
He's going to go kidnap his teammate.
He's going to go bring his teammate.
We can look to fight these guys.
I'm clearly right behind you.
Chip, you try to cross, but you have to do it at your own
discretion.
it without dying again i'm here there's one guy here on the
back side i'm with you they're trying to rotate it's a life
one life one low uh 10 minutes nice they said they're at the
nuts to the right door on me yeah crack them crack them
carry your left carry left there's another team i'm trying
to get the oh yeah yeah i can't see him i don't know where
he is just set up in here okay i'm breaking the castle bell
for you Do you want me to put the gen or no?
Go get that thirst.
No.
I'm going to run a TP across.
Be ready to take this.
We're going to try to kill this team.
Careful.
I think they're resing right here.
There's a bat here.
Take this right away.
They're in the nut across to our west.
We're looking to kill this team.
They're in here.
One is on the roof.
I'm in a wide angle out right.
You guys can just like work angles.
Wraith, one shot on roof.
Can you cross out right with me?
Let's move up the screen.
I'm gonna get shot at.
Bottom four on the right.
One died.
One is dead right now.
I don't have an angle.
Rapped right.
The angles are really good back here.
Like the rocks and shit.
Get a drill like right here.
On the bottom side of their nut.
There's like a staircase.
You hitting them?
All three?
Yeah, I'm gonna walk up on the store.
I'm walking up.
I'm right behind you.
Doki, jail this, jail this.
You have ball, you ball through the door.
And then we triple swing.
Swing, swing, swing.
I'm getting shot at by side.
That's what I mean.
Break dead inside.
Okay.
I'm going up to third floor.
Yeah, I cracked him.
Body, body, body, body in the door.
Behind you in the door.
Why?
Knock on, knock on the door.
You can climb on me, shifting.
Yeah, almost an armor.
I know it's only one up.
Only one up.
He's right.
Oh, beating, beating, beating.
No.
team i had to go they're mating in they're needing in oh
they got the res off they got the res they portaled out they
portaled out mac uh
the columns are the 13 just hiding in the water i have no
idea the caustic uh and that's howling on that third part
yeah the caustic shot me while i was trying to do the cross
they came from s top wall oh hey not last not last
difference it's still Yeah, it's true.
The costume just got me on the cross when I try to come in.
You should probably be fine.
Right?
Probably.
Yeah.
Yeah, I should have dropped the gen right off the bat.
You know, while all this is happening, I'm going to walk my
dog.
I'm going to breathe.
In case we make...
Oh, nice!
Yes!
Kill him!
That's you saying, yes.
I'm so happy.
Oh, yes.
Oh, but their wraith lives.
What's the point?
I was really hoping that their entire team would die.
Oh, wait, it's still possible.
I hope they dies, because then they'll have a zero-pointer
game, too, guys.
Yes!
Kill him!
Give them zero points!
say yes as long as they also get zero points yes hey hey no
no no you're the eight
hey i will watch no soon he doesn't get walkies at this time
i don't understand he just knows that i'm awake is there a
leaderboard is he like who's below us yeah it's on battlefly
yeah i sent you the link to it we have like a like a four
point gap between nine and then a seven between us and ten
oh that's close that's a little that's a little too close
for comfy
uh uh maybe we should not have into that
right we don't get thirded yeah we would have won that yeah
fucking shit on the second person I don't know who that was
I one-click the raid I got almost one click the other guy
169 how nice oh my god they get the res off and everything
that's bullshit I'm
so sad that link's not working for me but uh should i be
watching battlefly um okay you know how you
i'm believing you know the link that i sent you to join the
team that might i'll just i'll link i'll send the link yeah
yeah yeah and then and then on the right you see view lobby
information nah i mean i clicked the i'm on the battlefly
like yeah send this link to him that should be it mac just
in that one yeah oh that's a different link than the one i
have yeah but that's just exactly that's just straight to
the standings okay oh that's probably the one that that's
your chassis and it's not the player link that makes sense
okay group stand oh we're two or group one no we're group
one yeah we're at ranks we're number seven right now or
number fucking albert noodles so we gotta have a hate watch
on like a lot of people right now yeah hal just murdered
bolo i think or tempest did yeah
so this is put his jet on bolo's head when he was getting
drilled and they yeah oh man there's still so many teams
left all right i'm gonna go walk my dog for real if i and
then when i come back i'll figure out if we're in or not
i'll be right back probably fine gil and i have a decent
game i think yeah gil and we're i think jumping up a little
bit i think how and then we're about enjoy the game i'll be
right back i walk the dog and then you guys can cheer on or
not oh yeah i'll post the battle
I don't know.
We'll see.
Here's the battlefly link.
And I'll pin it.
I mean, if he's smart, I'll pin it.
He's like, go get the smartest name.
Let me, does the battlefly link work, guys?
Does it work?
Alright, go walk.
Alright, I'll be right back.
Well, people are dying.
We'll be right back.
Is there a way to get all this, like, stuff off of my
screen, like, when I was spectating?
Oh, like, the banner is on the right side?
triangle or why?
Stuff on the right side.
Everything else was there.
Hold on.
We got slime by Dauror.
Well, Sykes and I died.
They were ninth, I think.
That is amazing news.
He beats team.
Yeah, they are dead.
It kills the head.
Is this a match point or is it just games after no, it's
just it's just four games for each like set what in the
final lobby though Oh, that I think it's I think it's just
four.
Oh, okay Having content creators play match point would be
fucking crazy Hear that Match point's such a fun fucking
format though.
Yeah That's like the one thing like the one thing that is
like indisputable about apex comp where there's just like
one of the best union experiences match point yeah we hated
it originally like players but over time it kind of like
became like the identity of the sport now we all with it oh
it's before before it was just total points after six games
yeah so like people didn't like it because you could be like
the best team and like play the best and get the most points
and then not win the tournament yeah
at the same time at least like some crazy moments like games
really could end in like five games you know teams is going
insane that though but like i don't think that's really
happened before most of the time matchpoint at least on land
goes to like at least eight games yeah our first like worlds
was just six games and then after that like we did
matchpoint like it's like trademarked by apex so i'm pretty
sure like it costed money to just be able to even use it
probably yeah it was like ewc they did it then like they
probably just threw the bag idea i mean they're buying them
anyways yeah everything's match point now for us people
didn't really like it because like anticlimactic like the
land that like so i won the first like world's land that we
had and we were like 70 points above second so like it just
didn't really matter but we ended up winning the last game
though so i guess it like kind of helped Yeah, like everyone
knew when we went to last game like it was we already won
the tournament
I mean a 70 point lead that is fucking diabolical there.
Oh, yeah, we had like a 50 point lead going to last game and
like that That's like a lot.
So that's so I mean, that's a lot here, bro We had that we
would have had a throw to lose that and we won the last
game.
It's like it doesn't matter Yeah, I feel like you're like
you're like even like a 20 point lead is big Sorry, I'm
gonna 50 and first is like, that's fucking absurd.
Oh yeah, I gotta spectate panic on him, okay.
Panics are, are you spectating panic?
Yeah, oh, I'm just gonna roar right now.
Okay, Delro is his brother.
They're both roller players, but Panics playing this game on
him and K.
Yeah.
Panics are fucking goober on the keys.
He can shoot, but he just like tweaks out.
He starts moving goofy.
He's young, isn't he?
Yeah, he's young.
I think he's 19.
They just ripped Wayne's head off.
Yeah, snipers aren't allowed in our comp.
Yeah, see, in this, we got infinite ammo Kramer, so.
Should get real goofy in comp.
Someone's got that.
But, I mean, it's one of those guns.
We tried to get it, like, banned or, like, get it, like, at
least like to the point where You knew it was looking at you
like a glint or like a laser gun off it or something But
like the devs didn't want to do it.
It's like it's like a crowd favorite gun And when people hit
shots of the Krabber on land like the fucking crowd explodes
Now yeah, I was in the LA land, uh, what's that?
Oh, oh seven what are what are the players?
Uh, no, is it not some that nasty or?
Oh, was that the one where nasty and he went crazy?
We're fighting off spawn in Cedo.
I Don't know.
I wouldn't know the POI and so like that but i just knew
like the end game they got like paused on like a 393 and he
like went fucking like he had a crazy game and with the
graver like he he literally was hitting every shot and that
was like insane i hope you i went to land what said it was
that was uh the lane that was on yeah yeah there's an
infamous like contest that happened to cito between that
team and zach nível's like another like top icky where they
both literally just threw their land fighting over a drop
spot that's right and like it literally was like whenever oh
seven would kill zach's team like nasky's like standing on
the desk yeah he likes it up yeah he's like yeah yeah and
one time he stood on the desk and a team came and
third-party them off spawned just killed everybody yeah
that's one of like the most iconic fucking uh land moments
that the games have
2v2 Delrore, 801v2
He's good for one I think he's just against the noob now And
he fucking clips him out of his socks Jesus Christ Okay The
team that was already in first one So that's really good for
us I think if we don't make it It's going to be by one point
Which has happened to me before Okay That would suck.
Well, I'm pretty sure we're good.
I mean, we are tied with eighth, but we have better
placement, so they have one more kill.
So I don't know if that's how you get two tiebreakers.
Tiebreakers on this are based on placement.
Okay.
So we would have that over fluent base.
If they got zero, yeah.
Oh, that is true.
I think they'd, I'd assume to me them get a kill.
I can look at the...
match summary and say squad zero got 14 that game they'd be
at 20 they'd be under us
squidward and then got 12 they're already above us
and then got nine that would you did have seven in top eight
i'm assuming they do up i don't keep it a buck be close what
even is placement in this game like top eight uh 15 is one
10 is two seven is three five is four four is five three is
seven two is nine one is 12.
did we make it guys Did we make it?
I'm back.
Uh, don't know yet.
Alright.
It's all up to fate.
We're about to find out.
God damn it.
I hope I can't.
I was hoping I come back and I just know if I was thinking
like I come back and then everybody's gone.
Like in the VC.
I was like, oh, we didn't make it.
Like, I was just thinking, like, I wonder if everybody's
going to be in VC when I'm back.
If that's when I know, and we made it or not.
Pro, why are they not updating this damn board?
Oh, the Rafe's team made it for a lot.
Fuck that team.
God, I was heating up.
The second group is already, the second group already
processed everything.
No.
didn't make it we didn't make it by one oh my mac by one
fucking mac i will say you wanted to push that team it was
killable bro it was it wasn't though were they though back
who were they damn that's actually we just literally needed
one or two points that's unfortunate that's so sad No.
We thirsted any of those kills.
Couldn't.
We would have won the tiebreaker too.
Yeah, I mean, we couldn't.
It was literally like, we were literally just ran at by 13
by the time we got the knocks down.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, well, GG's guys.
GG, GG's.
GG's.
I mean, we had some good games.
Yeah, it was just unfortunate.
The last game was just very unlucky with the third party on
the team.
Yeah.
I'm surprised that I'm surprised that so many play teams
like Maddie should get so many points in the end.
That's crazy.
Who else didn't?
Oh my god, it's the team that we aped.
Matt, the team that we aped got the points because of-
That's actually fucked.
That's karma.
That's actually the team that we aped got 10 plays.
That's karma, Mac.
That's literally karma.
You we got knocked out by that cat that team She Yeah That's
actually fun because while you're gone.
I literally said there's a chance we miss it by one point.
It's happened to me before Yeah, there it is
They and and because they got points off of us too.
It just they got the they got the points off of us still if
they didn't get those two points off of me and ship these
bodies shouldn't have died gee fucking geez i should have
ate my thirst yeah
geez geez geez guys i'm gonna do with this coffee now all
right drink the coffee go back to bed anyway load up scrims
now ggs everyone all right later guys all right well the
fuck am i gonna do now i'm fucking awake i'm fucking awake
i'm i i knew i had a feeling too i was like we're gonna get
kern was so hard i wanted to be like why don't we chill on
the last game we're not technically safe.
But then I was like, Mac, Mac knows what he's doing.
What the fuck do I know?
I was just like, what the fuck do I know?
I haven't played this in a while.
But I was just like, fuck it.
I'll, I'll, whatever.
I'll list.
I'm a follower.
I always, I had that feeling too.
I was just like, maybe we should play safe.
Maybe.
Maybe we should have played safe.
But then the other plans always worked.
The other plans that we had kept working, though, you guys.
I was just thinking, like, we got so far.
Hey, not last, though.
Not last.
11th place.
11th place, but not last.
All right, guys.
I'm going to peace out here.
We do have another stream.
I'm fortunate that we got knocked out by one point.
yeah and it is unfortunate that we got knocked out by just
one point but i think i played pretty well in the last part
where i just got beamed in the cross because i was like
debating if i had to cross that because i did see the
caustic looking at me but i was like okay my team is
shooting his team surely he'll stay he'll like come back to
help his teammate and then he beat me on the cross So I was
just like, ah, fuck.
Well, I'm in.
I'm in.
Thanks for reading.
I'm already in too deep.
Like, I debated if I should have stayed outside.
But then he was like, get in.
And I was just like, I'm okay.
I'll get in.
I didn't have any nades, I think.
I don't know.
But, you know, it is what it is.
I'm just happy we weren't last.
we got a lot of points it was just uh like i said just
unlucky car get karma i always for me i would do last game
the safest just because like we weren't technically in the
safe spot um but you know it is what it is i just wasn't
confident in voicing that myself only because you know i
haven't been playing apex that much and mac is literally a
pro player so i was just like just let it ride
See what happens And then we let it ride We lost the 50-50
at the end Yeah Yeah we trusted the process Every time And I
had fun I had fun I don't think I did too bad For me Yeah
the I didn't think I do too bad Because I i i survived i
survived for i survived for so long until that last like the
one time the last game where i didn't survive that's where
everything everything fell apart but uh anyway guys i'm
gonna head off we do have a second stream at six i i don't
want to like do that you know because like i said i have a
lot of stuff to do um behind the scenes in preparation for
next week and i hope you guys enjoyed watching we didn't
make it to the second set but you know maybe it's a blessing
in disguise maybe it's a blessing in disguise um hey guys as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around and get that blood flowing and if you to stay up for
me head to bed because you deserve it hey i got to play me i
get to play watson i'm hot that was fun um bye bye everybody
thanks for watching the tournament bye guys bye
secret ending max sent me the let it ride gif you know what
i'm talking about let it ride you said he sent me the gift.
Let it ride.
All right.
Bye-bye, guys.
And I also did let it ride.